combatientes kurdos triunfantes desfilan
por las calles de hasaka en el noreste
de siria después de siete días de
intensos combates finalmente pudieron
recuperar el control de la prisión donde
se habían refugiado combatientes del
autodenominado estado islámico más de
180 personas incluidos unos 120
yihadistas murieron en el ataque que
duró una semana otros fueron capturados
dentro de la prisión las fuerzas kurdas
se aseguran de que todas las celdas
estén seguras pero la amenaza no ha
terminado por completo no muy lejos la
lucha continúa los combatientes kurdos
están respaldados por soldados
estadounidenses
el ataque fue llevado a cabo por un gran
número de mafiosos alrededor de 200 a
300 de ellos fueron preparados y
entrenados antes de colarse en la región
luego se les unieron células durmientes
desde el interior de la ciudad
esto es lo que queda en los vehículos
con trampas explosivas utilizados para
el asalto a la prisión es el ataque del
grupo estado islámico más mortífero y
sofisticado desde su colapso en 2019 los
asaltantes incluso lograron tomar a
personas como rehenes varios de ellos
eran niños según las fuerzas
democráticas sirias muchos fueron
utilizados como escudos humanos
estaba dentro en una misión médica
trabaje allí durante mucho tiempo mi
misión era evacuar a los heridos y
muertos pero luego no pude salir y me
atraparon
los civiles de la zona también fueron
tomados por sorpresa y obligados a huir
muchos de ellos encontraron refugio
dentro de esta mezquita
queremos estar a salvo y regresar a
nuestros hogares nos estamos muriendo de
frío aquí y estamos cansada de la
prisión de alcina en hasaka albergaba a
más de 3.500 yihadistas incluidos
combatientes extranjeros pero también
había niños 800 según unicef algunos
prisioneros huyeron pero el número real
es aún desconocido